لم يعد امام سائقي شاحنات البضائع في
السودان سوى الاستعداد لمرحله قد يطول
امدها ففي ظروف الحرب صار هؤلاء بلا غطاء
يؤمنوا عيشهم يعتمد عملهم على حركه
الاستيراد والتصوير للبضائع عبر الميناء
الرئيسي للبلاد في بورت سودان ومع بطء
حركه الميناء منذ اندلاء المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم تراجعت فرص عمل سائقيه
الشاحنات وانعكس ذلك على ظروفهم المعيشيه
والله معاناه ظرف ما في مصاريف حاجه ناكل
الحركه اللاسلك ده بيبقى لاعب في طريقه
تطلع مصاري احدى تداعيات الحرب تظهر هنا
في محيط ميناء بورت سودان يخفي تكدس
الشاحنات هنا وراءه تضرر اعمالي فئات
كثيره في المجتمع وفي مقدمتها العاملون في
قطاع النقل ويتجاوز الامر ذلك الى انخفاض
معدل التصدير وصعوبه وصول موده وسيلع
جديده الى الاسواق لنقلها من الميناء الى
الخرطوم وولايات عده فالخرطوم هي سوق
كبيره جدا سوق كبير جدا جدا فكان غالبيه
الشاحنات يذهبون الى الخرطوم ولكن الخرطوم
توقفت بسبب هذه الحرب عشان كذا غالبيه
الشاحنات الان متوقفه باستثناء سفن تحمل
مواد اغاثيه واخرى تجاريه انحسر نشاط
الميناء في الاونه الاخيره جراء تصاعدي
مخاوف في شركات الاستيراد والتصدير من
ارسال السكن الى البلاد
وترافق ذلك مع فرض شركات التامين تكاليف
باهظه على تامين السفن والعاملين فيها
فضلا عن تعطل معظم التعاملات البنكيه
المرتبطه المركزيا في العاصمه الخرطوم
هيئه الموانئ من جهتها تسعى جاهده الى
تطمين المتعاملين معها محليا ودوليا في
محاوله لاستعاده الميناء نشاطه المعهود
والسهل من الشمال الى الجنوب في امن وامان
وبنعتقد يعني الاخوه اصحاب السفن ملاك
السفن
والتجار عامه اذا جبر سوداني ان شاء الله
ما حيشوفوا الا امن وامان والشغل اسرع مما
كان قبل الحرب وقبل الحرب ليس كما بعدها
بنظر القطاع التجاري وحسابات الربح
والخساره وربما ذلك ما جاء على السلطات في
ولايه البحر الاحمر تصدر امر طوارئ بتنظيم
الرقابه على السلع الاستراتيجيه ومنع
احتكارها وتخزينها او رفع اسعارها تراجع
حركه الاستيراد والتصدير بسبب الحرب اثر
بصوره مباشره على حياه السكان وكبد
الاقتصاد السوداني خسائر كبيره واستمرار
الوضع على هذا الحال قد يدفع البلاد الى
مزيد من المعاناه وتدهور الاحوال المعيسيه
حمدي البكاري الجزيره من مدينه بورتسودان